hi my name is um cats I'm from Block
tacular we're at blog heckler and
Twitter or a UK blog conference we're
working at the moment on our first event
and one of our challenges is convincing
companies that they want to sponsor as
they want to invest in what we're doing
how do we help them make that leap
understand that what they're investing
in is that early platform involvement
and that it will be exponential for
their brand two ways one you listen so
you actually go to them and ask them
what they want to get out of it I mean
putting on a bench you know this with
this I mean putting on events people
just start going to where they think the
brands or organizations that should put
dollars into them without knowing if
they even believe in event marketing
might not even be your event they might
have decided theoretically that they
don't believe in event marketing or
they've allocated dollars somewhere else
so the biggest problem with sales people
is they don't listen so the first thing
you need to do is ask questions
is this even theoretically because the
second they say yes now you can compare
it to where they put their dollars
elsewhere the best way to get dollars is
to compare yourself to something else
they've done now if you're in your first
year the things they've done are more
established they're safer right the
thing you need to do is paint them a
picture and the picture you need to
paint them is reverse engineering the
most successful events ever and so you
should show them and you should do the
homework on how the first South by
Southwest actually happened how the
first lay web happened and what you'll
find out if you do the first lay web is
that the early sponsors get a discount
today and are saving themselves a
fortune you need to sell them a picture
first ask questions find out it's even
feasible second when you see what
happened is when you ask questions you
get data when they say yeah and then you
go which conferences they go these five
then you go watch what they do and you
say listen Timmy
you sponsored UK UK Expo dot you know
this and all they did for you was throw
your logo up here here's what I'll do
for you
when there's ways but you need to
reverse engineer from the actual
question got it I just wanna learn
something as well being being an events
guy so you're you have a conference that
pushes blogging or the benefits of that
is that right
time yeah essentially it's a business
conference for people whose businesses
blogging's it's for logging creatives
people people about design I'm creative
people show show them what's going on
with blog world in the u.s. it's a
humongous event it's going on june 4th
january 4th to the 6 in las vegas show
them the brands that involved show them
google and see what blog world look like
six years ago cuz i can tell you what it
looked like it was small now it's 80
times the size paint the historical
picture my question off the back of that
is to just to you just so i understand
when you say how do I convince people
what do you fundamentally want out of it
honestly like you just want you out if
you want money at the end of it no we we
want it to work on three levels we want
it to work for us as a business we want
it to work for the businesses we work
for and we want it to be amazing for our
attendees we don't want to shortchange
them so we want to create partnerships
between the brands and the attendees so
that they can story tell so that their
blog outreach is elegant and it's you
want to something else there's also
something else you should you should got
my YouTube page and watch the video
where I taught people how to get
advertisers on their blog yeah where I
just picked up the phone and called
somebody like the answer to your
question also is to knock on every
single door like I get this all the time
like how do we get a sponsor I'm like
okay like here I'm trying to move fast
on QA and give you more of the religion
than the church but like how many people
would you asked different companies but
we're targeting quite a nice get the
[ __ ] out of your knees okay you know
what I mean 31:50 is dick right so first
get out of here first find more because
if you have 30 to 50 I promise you and
don't make me double check because I'll
call you out there's probably 30 to 50
other things that are close enough right
did you ask wordpress automatic yes get
barley I know you I know you're looking
for but I also know that WordPress is a
blogging platform that has
[ __ ] money right so you've asked 3250
because you've narrowly decided you also
want to go to people who can get the
benefit of doing a better job of
pitching to bloggers for their bigger
benefit cuz that makes sense but you're
stuck you're stuck here and you need to
be looking here because by the way
you're running a marathon it's not about
this year get your money from [ __ ]
Pepsi I don't give a [ __ ] because if you
get the money then next year you can get
the right person right I mean people are
too cute about what they're looking at
me when I hear startups saying we want
to get the smart money I'm like [ __ ]
you're not gonna get any [ __ ] money
you know like like and so so I think you
need to get out of your zone and you
need to get your money yes you can be
cute later get your money and you can
gives you a whole nother year to build
up for next year to story-tell